[موسيقى]
الى حد كبير لم يؤثر مثلا فيما يخص السفر
باتمان الصعب الان على اي شخص
ان يسافر من الغرب اوروبا والولايات
المتحده للدخول الى روسيا فعليه ان
يسافر الى دوله اخرى مثلا دبي واسطنبول
ومن هناك الدخول الى روسيا وهذا يعني بان
الروس الذين اعتادوا على قضاء العطلات
مثلا في الدول المتوسط باتت خياراتهم الان
بين تركيا او دول الخليج العربي او ربما
الان بعض دول اسيا فهنالك بعض القيود في
هذا الخصوص ولكن علينا ان نتذكر
ان الشعب الروسي او غالبيه الشعب الروسي
يعتمدون بشكل اكبر على الخدمات المحليه
والبضائع والمنتجات المحليه روسيا لديها
اكتفاء ذاتي مثلا في المنتجات الغذائيه
[موسيقى]
لذلك فان الشعب تاثر بشكل اقل بكثير في
حياتهم اليوميه وحتى الانترنت
رقميا فهنالك بعض القيود ولكن في الحقيقه
مع استخدامي حتى خدمات
الاساسيه في امكانهم متابعه القنوات
المحظوره او التي حضرت على روسيا فمن
الصعب القول انه هنالك عرقله كبيره ولكن
بالتاكيد مع كل عمليات الحشد والشباب
الذين
الاكثر سيطلب منهم الخدمه العسكريه وحتى
الجيش الاحتياطي فهذا السبب عرقله كبيره
اجتماعيه
خاصه الشباب في هذه العمريه فاصبحوا هنالك
خروج كبير جدا
خلال سته اشهر الذين غادروا روسيا لتجنب
الاستدعاء الى الخدمه العسكريه حوالي نصف
مليون شخص سافروا الى الدول في وسط اسيا
وانما نظرنا في مدننا مثل اسطنبول ودبي
فنرى بكل وضوح وجود عدد كبير جدا من روسيا
في هذه المدن
حيث يتجنبون
احتماليه ندائهم واستدعاهم للخدمه
العسكريه
فالى الان
الاثار كانت محدوده
[موسيقى]